made in sky c'est le nom de la création
chorégraphique y aura lieu le 19
septembre à la commanderie à elancourt
tout saint quentinois peut y participer
une soirée de présentation avait lieu au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
partenaires du projet faire en sorte que
le public puisse participer à des
projets comme ça des projets collectifs
c'est toujours d aventure humaine
incroyable c'est vraiment du partage de
la rencontre c'est rentrer dans
l'univers d'un artiste d'un chorégraphe
et la chorégraphe du projet s'appelle
joanne leighton
c'est elle qui a proposé le made in à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est un gros travail collective ou en
participer individuellement pour former
cette pièce collective
on utilise les images de cascades de
roches et de rivières de glaciers on
s'inspire de ces images pour en fait men
et les mouvements de danse sur scène il
y aura cinq danseurs professionnels
accompagnés d'une centaine d'amateurs du
territoire la pièce durera en tout 40
minutes on aura les musiques qui sont
lancés en live en direct qui sont mixés
en direct avec le spectacle il y assez
noble fille avec deux grandes sphères
ajouté qu'ils sont dans l'espace avec
nous l'idée de ces projets participatifs
aucun niveau technique n'est requis à la
commanderie la mission danse propose de
nombreux projets du même genre on a tout
un groupe assez important de gens qui
sont friands de projets participatifs et
avec cette année qu'on vient de vivre il
était un peu en manque donc commencer la
nouvelle saison avec un projet
participatif la scène nous réjouit et se
réjouit à la fois aussi les habitants
les premiers ateliers débuteront samedi
11 et dimanche 12 septembre au théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
vous pouvez encore vous inscrire d'ici
là il reste des places